the hacker who hacked himself this
innocent looking guy from Finland is one
of the most immoral hackers in the world
Julius kivamaki started his career when
he was still a teenager he stole card
data and took part in money laundering
schemes and this is just a small part of
what he did by the age of 17 he stood
accused of more than 50 000 cyber crimes
but because he was only a teenager they
gave him a suspended sentence I can't
really think I feel bad in 2020 under
the nickname ransomman Julius got hold
of the therapy records of the Finnish
Psychotherapy Center vastana and
demanded a six-figure ransom the
Psychotherapy Center correctly did not
pay up then Julius began to extort money
from patients directly but here he was
in for an unexpected shock to take
revenge kivamaki uploaded his stolen
database to the dark net and
accidentally leaked his home folder
which investigators found so he hacked
himself Julius was in hiding for a long
time but on February the 3rd 2023 he was
detained in France at his girlfriend's
house who called the police reporting
domestic violence a bad ending for a bad
guy